people look for the shortcut the hack
the shortcut is a lie the hack doesn't
get you there there is no easy way there
is only disappoint you can't control
other people the only person you can
control is you you have control over
your - I'm nothing but weakness I did
that Nemoto over stupid things I eat the
wrong
I don't sleep enough i procrastinate I
waste time I care too much about stupid
things and not enough about important
things in all those ways I am weak but I
don't accept that
so often the easy path calls us
into that moment to give in to
short-term gratification
discipline will not allow that
discipline can seem like your worst
enemy
it is you best for it
disappointed they will make you a better
and stronger and smarter and faster and
healthier than anything else
the most important who will make you
free
discipline equals freedom